مبابي يعود لتدريبات سان جيرمان مانشستر
يونايتد يطلبوا طائرات مسيره ونادي لكره
السله يباع ب 40 مليارات دولار هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
صدمه نجم المنتخب
الكثيرين اثر عودته الى تدريبات فريقه
اليوم الاربعاء بعد ثلاثه ايام فقط من
خسارته نهائي كاس العالم وكان نادي قد منح
ميسي لعشره ايام لكن يبدو ان الشاب
الفرنسيه
الليله الماضيه صوره على انستغرام وهو
يحتفل بعيد ميلادها الرابع والعشرين
وفي مدينه روزيرو الارجنتينيه تم الاعلاف
منتظرين عوده ميسي الى منزله بعد احتفاله
مع الملايين من الارجنتين في العاصمه
بوينس ايرس وبذلت الشرطه المحليه الكثير
من الجهد كيف تفتح الطريقه لسياره ليو
التي كانت تقودها زوجته انتونيلا لكن ورغم
هذا بدل ميسي سعيدا بهذا الاستقبال الباهر
بعد رحيل رونالدو يبدو ان مانشستر يونايتد
قد بدا في تحسين بعض الامور الداخليه
لتصوير التدريبات الفريق من الاعلى كما
تحدث الطاقم الفني للمدرب الهولندي مع بعض
الفرق توفى فرنسا لتطبيق نظام نومهم
والحميه الغذائيه الخاصه بهم مع اللاعبين
وبهذا يستعدوا مانشستر يونايتد بافضل
طريقه ممكنه من النصف الثاني من الموسم
الذي انطلق بالفعل انجلترا
نادي لكره السله اصبحت ثاني اغلى نادي
رياضي بعد بيعه مقابل 4 مليارات دولار
المليارديرمات ايش بها قرر شراء اغلبيه
اسهم النادي الذي يلعبوا في دوري كره
السله الامريكي للمحترفين طبعا هذه الصفقه
ليست الاغلى في تاريخ الانديه الرياضيه
فلتتفوق عليها صفقه شراء نادي دنفر لكره
القدم الامريكيه والتي بلغت 4 مليارات
و600 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]